wir wollen jetzt noch einmal etwas näher
auf den tatverdächtigen christian b
eingehen wir haben ja gerade schon
thematisiert es könnte tatsächlich sein
dass er auch verdächtigt wird etwas mit
dem fall der vermissten inga zu tun
haben spricht das dafür dass er
besonders schlau besonders klug vorgeht
wenn man wirklich jahrelang gar keine
spur hat dass man muss man sagen er ist
täter in vielen vergangenen fällen aber
in diesen beiden fällen maddie mccann
und auch den zahlinger ist erst mal nur
tatverdächtiger ist spricht aber doch
einiges dafür insbesondere dann wenn
sich herausstellt dass er tatsächlich
der täter im fall maddie mccann ist dann
steigt die wahrscheinlichkeit auch ganz
erheblich dass er auch für den fall
verantwortlich ist warum fälle sind
immer dann leichter zu verbinden wenn es
charakteristische elemente gibt die man
verbinden kann
gegenbeispiel tür auf drei schüsse tür
zu das ist da gibt es so wenig verhalten
so wenig psychologie diese fälle zu
verbinden ist sehr sehr schwierig weil
es keine speziellen charakteristischen
elemente gibt manchmal zeigen täter aber
so genannte signature oder ritschel
verhalten das heißt sie machen oder
unterlassen bestimmte dinge neben dinge
zum tatort mit oder dinge vom tatort weg
das heißt es gibt irgendein merkmal
womit man fälle verbinden kann und in
diesem fall ist der modus operandi das
vorgehen bei der tat kinder aus gut
behüteten gegenden zu entführen ist doch
einigermaßen einmalig weder bei anderen
sexualstraftäter noch in der
organisierten kriminalität ist das
typisch maddie mccann wurde aus einem
hotel resort entführt und der
tatverdächtige hat passende vorstrafen
und war zu der zeit am tatrelevanten ort
und auch zu der zeit dort in dasselbe
gilt für den fall länger das vorgehen es
ähnlich es ist eine gut behütete gegend
in der ein kind plötzlich entführt wird
und seine vorstrafen passen zu dem
vorgehen und er war auch zu der zeit vor
ort das heißt es spricht einiges dafür
allerdings will ich einen schritt
zurückgehen das muss erst mal geklärt
werden ob er überhaupt sicher der täter
im fall maddie mccann ist wenn das der
fall ist hat es für doch recht
wahrscheinlich dass der fall immer auch
auf sein konto leider zu zählen ist
und wie geht man jetzt als ermittler
weiter vor im fall enke zum beispiel
jetzt soll ein bewegungsprofil erstellt
werden wie genau macht die polizei das
jetzt genau es geht darum herauszufinden
wo er sich aufgehalten hat erst mal grob
das kann man relativ sicher anhand von
fahrzeug anmeldungen oder dem wohnort
feststellen dann aber auch im detail
durch auswertung von handydaten und oder
telefonaten und oder zeugen die zu der
selben zeit am selben ort waren und
bestätigen können wo er war oder auch wo
er nicht wahr
offenbar wurde bereits festgestellt dass
er kein alibi für den zeitraum habt und
das ist natürlich erstmal einen
anfangsverdacht aber diesen verdacht in
vernünftige beweise umzuwandeln kostet
doch noch einiges an zeit und trotz dem
medialen interesse muss man dann den
ermittlern auch die zeit geben das
gründlich zu ermitteln